[Music]  fear fear will keep the local systems in  line fear of this battle station this  station is now the ultimate power in the  universe I suggest we use it state your  name for the record  gen arson our rebellion  it's all that remains to push back the  Empire we think you might be able to  help us what is this we've a mission for  you  a major weapons test is imminent we need  to know what it is how to destroy it  what will wouldn't it catch you if you  continue to fight  what will you become  the power that we are dealing with here  is immeasurable if the Empire has this  kind of power what chance do we have  we have hope rebellions are built on  hope  there isn't much time may the force be  with us  three  all the way  you